[Music]
when did they teach you that diversity
is not just the differences you like
it's not all samosas and egg rolls right
diversity is about disagreements there's
a great line diversity is not rocket
science it's harder because if you're
engaging people with whom you have
differences that you don't like that you
have disagreements you got to figure out
how you gonna engage those people does
the fact of that disagreement voting
differently in a particular election
disagreeing on fundamental issues right
immigration policy for example abortion
does that disagreement cancel any chance
of a relationship if it does we don't
have a civil society anymore right how
do you have PTAs or little leagues or
hospitals that's what a diverse civil
society is about the ability to disagree
on some fundamental things and still
work together on other fundamental
things that doesn't mean that you
bracket your disagreement forever part
of the beauty of working together on
other fundamental things is the ability
to build a relationship on something
that matters such that you might be able
to broach that disagreement with a
different tone but if we allow some
disagreements to cancel any possibility
of a relationship we're in we're in real
trouble as a society now of course there
are limits right I am happy to engage
just about everybody in the United
States of America and a conversation or
it'll be part of an athletic league with
them or to be on the PTA with them but
I'm not buying a brownie from the KKK
bake sale there are limits but I think
that in a diverse civil society when we
recognize that diversity is not just the
differences we like those limits are not
the person who voted differently from
you in the last election those those
limits are are the true barbarians and
the way the great political philosopher
defined the term barbarian is the
barbarian is the person who destroys the
conversation
civilization means people from different
backgrounds living together and talking
together the Barbarian as the person who
destroys the conversation I think that
person is beyond the circle of civil
discourse anybody else I'm engaging with
[Music]